junior year can hardly believe it we
need to talk about your sexual health no
no please no want you to be sick dad why
are you giving me these don't forget to
have fun yes well I have a lot of
rubbers for that specifically they think
you should branch out make some new
friends you never know what could happen
that's what I'm afraid of
[Music]
my letters are my most secret
possessions I write them when I have a
crush so intense I don't know what else
to do there are five total Peter
the most popular guy in school Kenny
from Camp Lucas from homecoming trying
to Ambrose from Model UN and Josh but
he's my sister's boyfriend what are you
doing nothing nobody else knows about
them hey can I talk to you I really
appreciate it but it's never I'm sorry
what I think it's really cool that you
think I have cold inspects the letters
are out women tell me about it
here's the thing I had to make it look
like I liked you so somebody else would
think I liked them
what if we let people think that we were
actually together let's do this
[Music]
I've never seen you so happy did you
mean what you wrote in the letter I mind
every single person in my life just
don't hide yourself okay
we can't just sit up in your room
writing love letters
you gotta tell people how you feel when
you feel it you never saw me
you